the morning panel is devoted to
hook of energy usage and Dave Lawrence
will moderate the panel Dave Lawrence is
currently a director of stone energy
corporation before joining stone energy
he served as executive vice president of
exploration and commercial for shale
upstream Americas and he was the
functional head of global exploration
for royal dutch shell from 2009 until
his retirement in 2013 Dave's also an
earth scientist and he received his
doctorate from the department of geology
and geophysics here at yale 1983 that
right Dave 1983-84 alright and we're
quite happy to have him here he's been a
member of the external advisory board
for the Yale climate energy institute
since its start in 2009 and I'm also
pleased to announce that dave has
accepted our invitation to serve as the
new chair of the YC I advisory board so
I'll let them introduce the rest of the
panel like Neil it's great to be with
this group of panelists who I think
represents a range of expert expertise
in a diversity of views that I think
will be greatly beneficial to us I
should say I'm very pleased to take the
this chairmanship role of the external
advisory board for yce I given the
leadership in the direction that it's
had in the past and the potential that I
see for it to have an impact and not
only areas of Technology and science but
also in the regulatory space and in the
communication space and in policy space
so it's a tremendous institution with a
lot of horsepower behind it and sessions
like this I think just go a long way
towards towards demonstrating that an
eel I thought it was great to present us
with these shells scenarios and the
l scenarios provide a plausible knee
really emphasize I hope you took that
away plausible scenarios that lead to
this amount of energy used by sector
this amount of energy used by different
geopolitical realms and therefore this
amount of carbon emissions and this is
different consequences but I also think
that you recognized that in those
scenarios there wasn't very much
difference in the early years and in the
end they all resulted in a significantly
higher amount of carbon in the
atmosphere which calls for what are some
disruptive technologies that may come
forward what will change the rate of
market penetration that we see which is
an area of great interest to me and I'm
highly cognizant of as we look at
different introductions of different
energy systems that there are things now
that we see that we didn't envision ten
years ago and the quote that we tend to
overestimate change in three years and
underestimated in ten in the energy
space i think is highly valid I liked
that quote in the comments but we
remember ten years ago we were looking
at lng imports in the US and now we're
looking at LNG exports the greatest
change in the energy space has come in
natural gas which was a dying industry
and now look at in these scenarios how
much it's taken its role in a ten-year
span it was not like that ten years ago
so what are the other technologies what
other policies regulations things that
could cause these scenarios as Neil so
eloquently presented to change for us
and I think that's why it's great that
we've been able to bring forward this
panel which is a panel of of again it's
a considerable expertise in a diversity
of fields in a diversity of geographies
and sectors so let me just introduce the
panel to you and I'll start with dan dan
is hillhouse professed dynasty who many
of you have met his hillhouse professor
of environmental law and policy with
appointments at both the yale law school
and the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies he served the
state of Connecticut as commissioner of
the Connecticut Department of Energy and
Environmental Protection dan is also the
author and editor of numerous
publications highly influential
publications and books including green
to gold how smart companies use
environmental strategies to innovate
create value and build so he'll bring it
i think a tremendous perspective to our
panel professor Zhang Jie Liang is one
of the leading economists in China
highly influential in one of the most
highly influential places on the planet
working on climate and energy policy I'm
hope I'm not underestimated I
underestimated in three years ten years
no but he is so he's worth listening to
and he's professor of economics and
executive director of the Institute of
energy environment and economy at
shanghai university in beijing he's he's
authored and led many studies important
studies and initiatives in china and was
a lead author in the last two IPCC
climate change project so welcome so
it's a privilege to have you and thank
you for traveling this great distance
dan did not need to travel a great
distance another great traveler is is
our next panelist is Karen Hussey is an
associate professor at the center school
of environment and society at australian
national university and an expert on
what is now being called the water
energy climate nexus which also i
thought that was great Karen that Neil
also raised that important point in his
introduction she has a book coming out
later this year on
that topic specifically so we'll look
forward to its publication next yes and
buying that it'll be from Cambridge
University Press and she's the author of
environment and sustainability a policy
handbook so welcome and thank you again
for traveling and chill provide us also
some unique perspectives and Luke Tony
shell is a highly respected senior
vehicle analyst for the National Natural
Resources Defense Council he's based in
New York I note that today Luke walked
here which is good than well done Luke
and where he studies ways to reduce the
environment environmental impacts of the
world's transportation system and again
you can think of that impact as you
looked at one of neil's chart spit
specifically on what will happen with
liquid transport fuels and what may
change that to time he also served in
the US navy so that brought him a lot of
perspective on operations and propulsion
as an officer on a navy cruiser so
welcome Luke now in our panel
everybody's been given kind of strict
instructions we'll see how we do to stay
within somewhere between five and ten
minutes and and for their opening
remarks that'll give us a useful
perspective and then we'll open the
discussion to the panelists for
discussion I'll ask some questions the
panelists you're welcome to ask each
other questions and most importantly we
welcome questions from the room so we're
going to leave ample time I think for a
good and open discussion and with that I
think I'll turn over to you Dan to start
off speed up our movement from
presentations and opening comments to
conversation I'll stay seated and I do
think the conference that's been
organized here focuses on a critical
issue at a critical moment which is the
world is changing very fast a lot of the
assumptions we had about what the world
would look like in the years ahead have
been radically shifted in the last few
years three four years
so the world going out to 2030 looks
very different today from what people
asked the same question would have said
at the turn of the century for app for
example 15 years ago obviously the
biggest piece of that in some regards is
the emergence of shale gas tight oil and
the real revolution in the potential for
fossil fuels continuing to play a
central role in our energy future for a
much longer time that some people had
thought but I think at the same time we
see mounting pressure despite policy
failures particularly in Washington and
to some degree internationally on the
issue of climate change and a growing
recognition that that pressure has to be
responded to and will be responded to
one way or another and having just come
from the experience of working in a
state government I feel actually
optimistic that the United States is
going to respond and I say that despite
the fact that Washington is clearly
dithering and has not been able to
create a strategy that really helps
grapple with this world of change that's
emerged in the energy arena but I am
excited to see companies taking these
issues on frontally Neil's presentation
on shell was a fascinating example of a
company stepping up at the heart of this
issue in very creative ways a
forty-dollar shadow price on carbon
that's an extremely interesting way for
a company to position itself for success
in the years ahead and not simply to
wait to be buffeted by regulatory change
or other factors that might overtake it
and I would tell you just as companies
are stepping up so too are a number of
states and Connecticut for example under
Governor Malloy created for the first
time ever a comprehensive energy
strategy for the longest time States
thought that energy was national policy
and it could be left to Washington
nobody today thinks that that is a wise
place to leave your state and to leave
its citizens and frankly to leave your
businesses in a very competitive
marketplace so you see States stepping
up and I think in Connecticut there were
some interesting signals about what the
policy framework of the future has to
look like and how smart governments are
aligning incentives to be
ready for the change that's coming some
of it doesn't seem like rocket science
but it is important for example I was
head of a Department of Energy and
Environmental Protection the acronym was
deep deeeep but I used to joke and the
governor actually insisted that we spell
deep with 3 e's energy the environment
and the economy as an integrated set of
issues that had to be understood as a
package that needed to be thought
through on an integrated basis and I
think in the energy arena more broadly
we're seeing a very significant change
from a 20th century approach to energy
to a new 21st century approach and a
caricature slightly but not too greatly
the 20th century approach had a bunch of
smart folks some of them at least at the
Department of Energy in Washington from
a u.s. perspective this is trying to
pick winners winning technologies
winning industries winning companies and
frankly the track record is not that bad
but not that good and we've spent twenty
billion dollars as a nation invested in
one big alternative fuel for the future
and it probably everyone in this room
knows it is corn-based ethanol and
having just said the 20th century model
is to have the government pick winners
and it's not a very good thing I'm
willing to pick a loser and it's corn
based ethanol and I just think the the
energy transfer takes three units of
fossil fuel input to get four units a
corn-based ethanol out the food fuel
trade-off it creates the stress on water
systems that I hope will get some more
on in a few minutes makes this a loser
for sure so the government picks winners
not on the basis of market logic or
sustainability or ability to meet the
needs of society over time but on
short-term political logic that almost
always is not a good basis for driving
major investments so I think you see in
Connecticut a new approach emerging not
the government picking winners not
subsidy but a finance approach creating
a platform for entrepreneurial activity
and relying on our limited government
resources or ratepayer funds to leverage
private capital why is that important
first of all the government doesn't have
enough money to do
all the projects to invest in all the
infrastructure and to support all of the
efforts that need to be undertaken
second and more importantly relying on
the private sector provides a discipline
that government's lack and where the
money gets spent so it transforms
completely how you deploy your limited
resources and I think Connecticut's
already seen a boom in its clean energy
flow of capital into efficiency into
renewables into fuel switching towards
cheaper cleaner and more reliable
natural gas and out of coal and oil in a
way that is quite fascinating and it's
not by accident it does require kind of
a new policy framework so you see in
Connecticut not solar Rex and wind Rex
which is the old 20th century model but
as zero emissions renewable energy
credit that requires all technologies to
compete against each other so you're
harnessing market forces competition in
particular to drive down the cost of
renewable energy and I promise you the
single most important factor for whether
we get to a clean energy future is the
pace at which the cost of clean energy
renewable power in any of its forms
comes toward approaches and finally
surpasses the price of fossil fuel
alternatives particularly the generation
of power that's the key to success in
this marketplace and structuring policy
incentives to get there is what's
absolutely critical now beyond that
connecticut used a set of reverse
auctions to drive down costs it used
power purchase agreements as opposed to
a renewable portfolio standard to again
lower costs and it turns out that some
of the prevailing wisdom of the 20th
century just didn't work a renewable
portfolio standard which Connecticut's
had for 15 years ratcheting up the
percent of power that's meant to be
renewable up to twenty percent by 2020
has produced zero great scale renewable
energy projects in 15 years 0 no wind
projects no solar arrays because it's a
target it's a timetable it's a command
and control approach it doesn't work
what did work was saying the state would
like to purchase renewable energy all of
you who have projects tell us what you
can do and at what cost and we will give
you if you are the low bidder a 15 or
20-year contract to sell power in the
state of Connecticut so the number of
people that were able to get projects
financed when they had a
energy portfolio standard 2.2 in
Connecticut 0 once you have a contract
in hand you can go to a bank and borrow
a hundred million dollars to build a
wind farm very different approach so we
are seeing new tools that work a more
integrated strategy a focus on a
portfolio approach to the future there
will be a fossil fuel dimension to it
for some many years to come but we are
at the same time ramping up renewable
energy ramping up efficiency and by the
way after years of very slow ramp we saw
a 10-fold increase in the pace at which
renewable energy is being deployed at
the household scale and the grid scale
in the last couple of years as opposed
to the years prior to that we also are
seeing a need for integration not only
of strategy but of states it doesn't
work for each state to do this on their
own we're waiting for a national a
national program that's not coming so
you now have the New England states
banding together investing again in a
portfolio approach that has transport a
trance the transmission lines being
built as gas pipelines being built is
really designed to ensure that the state
is going to be able to benefit from the
markets that are out there and the
prices that are prevailing in some
places and I just point out natural gas
because of the growing supply is selling
in New York today at prices under the
bench mark henry hub in the gulf the
price in New England double that this is
a bottleneck problem and an
infrastructure issue so the New England
states are working together to overcome
that my bottom line and really what I
offer as the key to the 21st century
strategy is the need to think about
innovation more broadly than it was in
the 20th century a lot of push was put
on technology development remains
important we want to continue to see
venture capital not so much government
money but venture capital going in to
breakthrough technologies but we need
innovation as well in finance which is
why Connecticut set up a green bank to
do these kind of creative financing we
need creative policies new frameworks of
incentives we need innovation in how we
engage the public in the marketing of
clean energy so its innovation broadly
in the entire ecosystem of energy that
is what's going to get us to a
transformed future and is allow us to
manage these fast changing issues
that we see around us thank you Dan I
think we will have a lot of good
discussion on winners vs losers
economics trumping others this portfolio
approach is an essential approach and
it's great to see the success that it's
helped deliver in in connecticut and i
think the clearly as we talk and look
towards China things like looking at
infrastructure and the challenges of
distributing to different markets will
become a common theme